-So thank you, very
much for being here
and I'd really like to
obviously thank the Radcliffe
Institute for all that
they've done to facilitate
this strange adventure.
And in particular, I'd like
to welcome those of you who
are from disciplines
other than mine,
because I don't think
anybody from my discipline
is here which is fine.
People in my discipline don't
usually do this sort of thing,
and only a place
like the Radcliffe
can you expand your wings a bit
and try something different.
This exploration-- which
is really at the beginning,
we start in September,
and because it's
a late start this year
we've been at this
less than two months.
--is outside, but
overlapping my direct area
of work and research.
But, I did run a trial
balloon and ran it
by some others in
related fields.
We did an exploratory
seminar about a year ago,
and Radcliffe came to the
rescue to keep this idea going
to see what would come of it.
I was surprised and gratified
to get this fellowship.
I'd like to give special thanks
to the Bradley family who
helped make this possible.
And also, to say
that I was glad when
I was looking into the
Radcliffe fellowship
to look at a promotional video
for the Radcliffe Institute
and I saw a professor
Faust saying,
not all these
projects go anywhere.
So I felt relieved
that I would not
be totally on the hook to
actually necessarily make
it be a success, because
that's what exploration is,
that's what exploration
is in science,
and that's also what
exploration is in medicine.
So what I hope to cover in
this talk are three themes,
and I'm going to warn
you ahead of time,
there are mixed metaphors.
You're going to be
swimming in metaphors
and I hope you can
keep them straight,
because I struggle
with it myself.
There are many,
many, disciplines
upon which we will touch in this
exploration and in this talk,
and I will tell you
upfront most of them
I know almost nothing about.
So there may be those of
you who came to this talk
seeing it publicized,
and knowing
quite a bit about
the disciplines
that I'm going to be
skating on the surface of,
and you're going
to say to yourself,
she doesn't know what
she's talking about,
and I'm telling you
right now, you're right.
So what I would ask you
is, contribute, talk to me
afterwards, be part of this.
If you think that the
idea has any worth,
and even if you think the
idea doesn't have any worth,
I'd still like
your contribution,
because as a scientist you don't
want to have a theory that you
then find evidence to support.
You want to have a question,
which you then find evidence
to refute, or direct
further inquiry.
There are three specific
things that we're
trying to accomplish this
year in this project,
and I put the picture "books"
there, because in fact it's
all book research.
People said, are you going to
put patients in an MRI scanner?
You're going to be put
deep brain electrodes in?
And no, we're basically
reading, and thinking,
and asking questions,
and your input truly
is welcome any of you.
My goal for this talk is modest.
I hope that by the
end, you at least
know what the title means.
So each of us brings
to our efforts
in life, our background.
And I will say, that I
think the single thing that
has pushed this into
my effort sphere,
has been a tendency that I
didn't know the word for,
until I started this project,
and the word is Biophilia,
and I have it bad.
This is a picture I took
hiking, two weeks ago on one
of those beautiful fall
days, and my whole life
has been spent
wallowing in Biophilia.
And most of you maybe
have heard this term,
it was popularized here at
Harvard by Professor Wilson.
It was actually coined by
the psychologist Erich Fromm,
and it's the idea that we
inherently, genetically,
have an affinity for things
that are natural and alive.
And I'm not 100% convinced
that we know that this
is inherent in our genes.
There's some suggestive
evidence that's quite good.
But I also think it
may be imprinting,
and I sometimes think that
like little ducks following
Konrad Lorenz around
here, I imprinted on trees
and for that reason this
condition is the part
of my life for a long time.
Now there's another thing I've
learned since starting down
this exploratory
pathway, which is
there's a flip side of
Biophilia and there's
a term for it which
I didn't know,
this is where Radcliffe
comes in useful,
it's called eco-depression
and it almost
sounds like a joke,
Eco-depression.
But in fact there is a study of
this topic of eco-depression,
and I can tell you
that once I started
reading about this I
can say unequivocally,
I suffer from this in a big way.
Every time that I
see a forest that
used to be where I
grew up, now plowed
down to make another housing
development or strip mall.
Every time I fly over the
United States and I look down,
and it's not being as far as
the eye can see but cultivated
land, I think of the fox
and what's that mother fox--
where are they going to go-- and
I have a nurse practitioner who
is southern, and she
taught me the expression,
it hurts my soul, and
that's how it feels.
And I bet some of you who are,
are here because you feel some
similarly.
Since college, I was
in college at Brown
in the '70s it was liberal
era, and we were really
worried about overpopulation.
And I still worry
about overpopulation.
I worry about this
when I'm in crowds,
when I travel around the
world and I see crowds,
and you think what has
happened to all these people,
and it's still going on.
And when you see the effects
of what humans have done
and they can be very
emotion-grabbing effects,
like the ones you see at
the bottom of the slide.
So that's what we
call eco-depression.
So that's the substrate on
which this project arose.
And we're really going
to be pulling together,
attempting to pull
together threads
from many different sources.
We may end up at the bottom
on the right, a big mess,
and nothing may
come that's useful.
We're looking to see if we
can find something that's
interesting, and maybe
even has utility,
like you see on the left,
but it's still early.
So we have three specific
aims for this year,
and thank heavens, the
Radcliffe Institute
lets you have research partners.
So I have five brilliant
enthusiastic undergraduates,
and I picked them for their
specialties, for their majors,
they're all upper
class students.
And I have an environmental
psychology student,
I have other psychology
students with interests
in public health, I have
basic neuroscience students,
I have environmental
science students,
and people with
background in economics.
So we have some
diversity on purpose
to try to have them be my-- as
we see in the immunology world,
effector arms-- go out
there, and to mix metaphors,
to go on safari and find
stuff and bring it back.
So we're hoping
to write a thesis,
whether this becomes
a book or not, I'm
trying not to be too ambitious.
We're designing an
interdisciplinary course
to see if people are
interested in exploring this
across disciplines on
a more ongoing basis.
And then the last thing
is also an ambitious part,
which I won't talk much
about, although anybody
that wants to talk more to
me about this I'd be happy.
To bring this back to my world
in neurosurgery in children,
to work towards an experimental
green children's hospital.
Looking at whether the reward
system could be capitalized
upon to make work
even more rewarding,
because of the pro-social
aspect of this.
So what are we
talking about here,
I just want to say thanks,
at this point for the trial
balloon that we put
out about a year ago,
when I got together
a few colleagues
in the clinical neurosciences.
Alice Flaherty was
absolutely essential,
she's a brilliant
neurologists, and also has
an appointment in psychiatry,
and has written books,
and was a Radcliffe fellow
which is kind of how I got here.
And Zelime Elibol is a young,
ambitious, very bright, child
neurologist who
specializes in adolescence.
And we came up with
this idea and we
want to put on a
seminar, and the person
who tipped the scales
for me was Dan Schrag
at the Harvard University
Center for The Environment, who
agree to sponsor this
exploratory effort.
And we pulled together a variety
of willing, and incredibly
generous people from
different disciplines,
including environmental
science, behavioral economics,
neuroscience of various sorts,
psychology, and so forth.
And we just got
together and went
through a series of questions
to explore, whether or not,
this idea might have
teeth, as we say.
And it was very, very, useful.
So what are we talking
about with these threads,
and this metaphor, what we're
talking about pulling together
themes, and I'll elaborate
on this in a moment.
And in addition we're
looking for data.
So as a person
trained in science,
I don't want to
just have themes,
I want to see what data are
out there, that could support,
refute, or modify,
these ideas of how
things might be connected, this
is really about connections.
So let's go on this journey
together, so Theme 1.
Theme 1 is this,
there are big problems
beyond our daily
workplace, and maybe
they deserve our attention.
And so you could argue that
this is a midlife crisis, this
is Biophilia, why don't
you just quit your job
and go be an
environmental scientist.
And I will tell you that
about 15 years ago I
thought about that,
because I thought
that the environment was the
biggest problem facing us.
I thought bar none, now we
might get hit by an asteroid,
there might be a
pandemic, there might
be a nuclear annihilation,
but the one we can see,
and the one that we
know about, is this one.
And I actually went to the
head of environmental science
at Brown, and said, should I
change careers because I really
think this is
important, and he said
no you should work
within your field.
And that's sort of part
of the genesis of this.
And here is my daily life, you
can see it, these are children.
Here I am in surgery.
These are children
with brain tumors,
with terrible traumas
to their brain,
with epilepsy, with
areas of the brain that
are causing abnormal
electrical activity that's
disabling the child, and happens
to be intersected perfectly
with the child
dominant hand cortex.
These are children
with tumors that
will cause their death, if
they're not removed, and will
cause paralysis if
not removed today.
These are children with
congenital problems,
the child in the bottom
right has a malformed skull
that needs to be taken apart
and put back together safely,
without harming the brain.
And this is what my day
consist of, and my life.
And it's very easy
to get narrow,
and to get very caught up in
it, and to be quite satisfied,
but I was nagged because of
this disease of Biophilia
and eco-depression,
that there may
be something else to be done.
And I think the thing that
tipped the scales for me
was this particular article,
now those of you who
are in environmental science
are the true scientists,
but then there are those
people who make this available
and bring it to the
attention of the public.
This was an article not
in the scientific journal,
but it was in the Atlantic.
It was part of a
millennial series
that the Atlantic monthly
put out right around 2000,
this came out in 1998,
they had a series of these,
of big ideas for the millennium.
And Bill McKibben is one
of the most prominent
environmental writers
in the US today.
And this was a three
part article, called
A Special Moment In History.
And it changed the
way that I thought,
and I think it changed
my life trajectory.
I kind of thought population was
the problem, and this article
whether those of you who
know more about this than I,
may disagree, so
I grant you that.
But this was the
article that showed
that in historical
time, from 1750's
up to the current time
that this was written,
there has been as we now know.
But in 1998, I was
less aware of it,
I knew a little bit about
but it hadn't really sunk
in that this was my problem.
And it shows this
dramatic change
in carbon in the atmosphere
due to different sources,
and as for those of
you in the visual arts,
I know a lot of my
fellow fellows are here,
look at this beautiful
way of showing
this superimposed on that
eco-depressive smokestack
that lines up.
Isn't that a beautiful way to
make you feel bad about it,
and effectively.
In this graph, I've
changed this scale here,
so these are on the
same scale here.
And this is global
carbon output,
carbon being the metric
we can study easily,
and is the metric for
greenhouse gases in general,
although I recognize it's
not the whole problem.
And this is the United
States, and you can just
see the difference between
where the whole world is,
and where the United States
is, this map of course
shows the high output countries
and we're right up there,
we're right up there
despite the fact
that our population
is much smaller.
And the metaphor that Bill
McKibben in this article used,
that made a big impact on me,
was this one of the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day balloons.
So he says that in the
United States, if you
talk about how much
carbon each of us
produces in our daily life,
through things we consume,
through the travel that
we do, through things that
are workplace,
through our houses,
and the heat that's wasted
through the food that we eat,
it gives us an amount.
And we carry around an amount
like the biggest Macy's
Thanksgiving Day balloon,
whereas these places
with growing population
have much, much, smaller
kind of at the sidelines
on the parade balloons.
And therefore, the point that
he made that made an effect on
is, this is us,
this is our problem,
this is our responsibility,
which I had not really
felt prior to this.
This the population
expected to grow over time,
this is where the
United States is now,
these are the ones
that are up and coming,
and if those people
all live like we live,
we cannot stop that tie, is the
impression I came away with.
So what are the fixes, well
technologic advances, carbon
independent energy
sources, for those of you
who have not seen
it, this is a still
from the video that you
can get online that went
viral, called solar roads.
People can complain whether
solar roads are practical,
but it's a great video,
again it's a crowd sourcing
video, it's persuasive, although
those in the technical fields
have their criticisms of it.
Geoengineering, many of you
know about this, many of you
are very interested in this,
some of you may do this.
Population control
is critical, but I
don't need to tell anybody
here how difficult that is
and how many factors, economics,
religion, and other things
go into making that
difficult. And then there's
behavioral change, which we
think about, when we think
about it, about our own lives.
Should I recycle, should I
do this, should I do that,
but if you really think about
it, all the things on that list
will involve behavioral change.
It isn't just what
we individually do,
it's what we collectively value.
And so, I think behavioral
change is a key ingredient that
cannot be ignored, whether
it's on the individual level,
the societal level, or
the governmental level.
This also came from
Bill McKibben's paper,
and at the time,
here was my reaction
which I've kept and was the
genesis for this project.
And he says, one
would think offhand
that compared to changing the
number of children we bear,
changing consumption
patterns would be a breeze.
Fertility, after all,
is biologic, hardwired,
like Darwin said.
But, he says in
his paper, I would
guess that is easier to change
fertility than lifestyle.
And he concludes, based
on this population curve,
that we simply won't live
simply enough, soon enough,
to solve the problem.
Talk about eco-depression,
nothing we can do about it.
But at the time when
I read this in 1998
as a practicing neurosurgeon
who has an interest in behavior,
a background in
psychology, and interest
in those aspects
of neuro surgery
that have to do with
brain and behavior,
that didn't seem
surprising to me.
And the reason it
didn't seem surprising
is that simplification is hard.
And the reason simplification is
hard has to do with our brains.
So that was theme one.
This will pull together,
I hope, but now we're
going to move on to theme two,
which I'm calling our brains,
ourselves.
For those of you who are old
enough, Our Bodies, Ourselves.
We're in the right
place for that.
So, here's the
principle, it's more fun
to get more than
to do with less.
And another way
of saying that is,
that we'd like to get stuff.
Now, when you illustrate
getting stuff,
you usually have women
with shopping bags,
but I have guys in a bike-shop.
Because, in my family the
guys in the bike shop,
spend as much as the women
with the shopping bags--
I'm being sexist
here, but I just
like to put guys jumping
on this picture--
And another way of saying
that is, it is more fun,
or you can say rewarding,
or you could say satisfying,
to get more, or to do more,
or to experience more,
than it is to simplify.
And we know this
inherently, this
is a travel poster trying
to get you to travel,
we love to travel,
get new experiences.
This is a solitary
confinement, it's torture.
And this is not
this is not made up,
this is explained by
how our brains work.
So what do I need?
Our brains evolve for survival,
you all see those squirrels
out there getting
those nuts right now,
you step on those nuts
when you walking don't ya?
And, they're doing
it for a reason.
Their brains and our brains have
this in common, early humans
had this in common, they stored
their fish, they had shelter,
this was survival.
And people who are someone at
the extreme end of the belief
and behavior, and genetics,
write books like-- and get
these concepts across--
The Selfish Gene,
that says that our
bodies are basically
just the carriers for the
genes, which are really
the elements of importance,
and that we're just
carrying machines.
Be that as it may, our
brains evolved for survival,
and some of the ways we
are, make perfect sense
from that point of view.
And in order to accomplish
this, certain things
had to be rewarding.
We needed to develop
a reward system, which
is present in virtually all
organisms, if you look for it
and think about it in that way.
And in humans it's
exquisitely well developed
and it happens to be
at a time right now,
when this circuitry
and its interactions,
are being explosively
understood in new ways.
And the reasons for that
is that the way we used
understand what does
what in the brain
is through lesions, accidental
or otherwise, some of you
have seen The Phineas Gage
exhibit here on the campus,
and this was a tamping iron
that went through someone's
frontal lobe, and
changed his behavior,
and his reward system.
Those were the kinds of clues
we used to have to go on,
to figure out
where things where,
and how they acted in the
brain; people with strokes,
people with tumors, people with
surgery, the kinds of things
I do.
But now we have new tools to
see why this is rewarding,
and what happens, and why
this child so ecstatic
with figuring out that a
butterfly landed there and now
landed here.
And it's being explored
at an increasing frequency
and sophistication,
by two techniques,
One is deep brain stimulation,
which was originally designed
to treat people with diseases.
And now even though people
have diseases that get these,
no people volunteer-- yeah,
I'll sign up for that study,
put a deep brain stimulator
in, just for fun.
Using deep brain stimulation
in many different networks
of the brain, for
various conditions,
has created enormous opportunity
to study how this system works.
Functional MRI is
another type of study,
which also has
been revolutionized
in the last decade.
It's task based,
sometimes you can do this,
and this part of your brain will
change its blood flow enough
that a magnet can pick it up.
There's resting state
fMRI, which picks up
what's connected to what.
And now, my former
resident Kendall Lee
has figured out a way to do
deep brain stimulation in an MRI
scanner in a
magnetic environment,
it's kind of amazing using
carbon fibers and Bluetooth,
and figure out how to do
functional MRI and deep brain
stimulation at the same
time to actually see
how these networks
work, and are modulated.
And it's really
quite extraordinary.
So I'm not going to say that
I, or that the field knows
everything about
it, but what we know
is increasing in complexity
minute to minute.
The problem is
perhaps as follows,
so our brains evolved with
this wonderful system,
but it doesn't
know when to stop.
And so, now, you urges to
eat get you into trouble,
and your urges to get stuff
are getting the planet
into trouble, or both.
And so, our brains
are still living
in some other era, when
this was not so problematic,
but it has become problematic.
And what neuroscience
gives, in my mind,
is an arm's length
tool to not judge it,
to not say, you're a jerk for
having a house like that, don't
you know better than to eat
that, it's to hold it at arm's
length objectively,
and say, what
is it that makes good,
well intentioned,
people who don't really want
to see the planet destroyed,
do this.
What is it about our brains that
promotes this kind of behavior,
or makes it hard to change,
or hard to simplify.
So as proof, what's more fun,
to look at the kind of car
you're going to get, pick out
the color, pick out the model,
or look at the gas mileage.
And what's more fun,
to decorate your house,
to get furniture
for that front porch
and think about what the
trim color is going to be,
or to put insulation
in your attic.
So the reward system
for those behaviors,
that are increasing the
problem are just greater,
than those things that
tell you to contract,
do-less be sensible.
In many ways is the theory
that we're exploring.
I'm not saying that
I know the answer,
I'm saying that
some of this seems
to be as one might
say common sense,
but common sense from
a brain point of view.
And what we've been exploring in
our project, my students and I,
is the evidence to support
or refute this idea.
One interesting paradoxes
is that stuff doesn't even
make us happy.
So, if you're starving, food
makes you happy of course,
if you're cold, a warm
sweater makes you happy.
But there now are--
and many of these
came out of Harvard as well--
many happiness studies,
there's a whole
field of happiness
that didn't exist when I was in
the beginning of my journeys.
And it turns out that
relationships, and meaning
and experience, all make
you happier in the long term
then stuff, but stuff makes
you happy at the moment.
And a former professor
of mine has come back
into my consciousness, and
I've been working with him
on this, neuroscientist
named Peter Sterling, who
study the visual system, but
also is interested in this,
and is his belief that evidence
suggested that the reward
system that we evolved with and
that we still have today, all
of us sitting here, is tuned to
small unexpected and variable
rewards.
We're tuned because we evolved
at a time of relatively
consistent misery.
We were pretty much always
hungry, and pretty much always
cold, and wet, and
physically uncomfortable.
So the biggest rewards
come from a patch of sun,
that you stand in for
a minute, or 10 berries
that you find the wayside.
And that his idea
is that the way
we live our lives,
our rewards, we
need more and more,
and more rewards.
Because they're not like this
anymore, they're consistent,
they're predictable,
and we need more,
and more, and more of them.
It's his belief,
that this is part
of the explanation for
certain kinds of addiction,
and certain kinds of
alienation in modern life,
now I'm not saying I necessarily
I'm going to go all that way,
but it's an interesting theory.
Now, I talked about rewards that
generally we think of as bad,
they're consumptive
rewards, we eat too much,
we have too much stuff,
our houses are to big,
our carbon footprint
is enormous.
But, let's talk about
other kinds of rewards.
Humans evolved to be
rewarded by new insights,
how many people have seen
a child with a puzzle?
With a new toy?
with a new playroom?
With-- and outside,
go and explore it.
This is normal behavior from
rats, probably from paramecium,
all the way to human
children, and human children
in particular, are
rewarded by novelty.
We take advantage of
this in the hospital.
I know you would disagree,
many of you with this,
but kids actually
need a whole lot less
or no pain medicine
after procedures
if you give them a video game.
I know, bad thing,
but you know what,
in most children's
hospitals now, kids
get video games after surgery.
Because they did much
less pain medication, why?
Because, novelty and stimulation
is extraordinarily rewarding,
and exploration
and puzzle solving.
And, one of the wonderful
things about being at Radcliffe
is that you meet people from
all different disciplines,
and these are happen to be
three people I really admire,
Esti Yeger-Lotem, and Karol
Armitage, and Phil Klein,
all of who are on my floor, it's
kind of like being on a dorm,
you get to know them.
And each of them has expressed
in talks that they've given,
that they love the problem
solving aspect of this,
and that solving a
problem, whether it's
3D spatial movement of
the physical bodies,
or whether it's
computational stuff,
is-- that I don't understand--
is really rewarding.
And in fact, so rewarding,
that they call it beautiful,
they find beauty, in these
problems that they solve,
which tells you how
rewarding it really is.
Now, I live in the
world of physicians,
and you know your colleagues,
you spend more time
with your colleagues
than your family,
my daughter's here so
she attest to that.
What are doctors like?
I can tell you what
surgeons like, by in large
most of the surgeons I know.
Let's leave out the
income part, and they
like to have a good car, and
all that, let's leave that aside
for now because those
are sort of universal.
But what the people
in my business
really get a kick out
of is problem solving,
and they're reward by altruism.
And I know myself if I'm honest.
I get the biggest kick out
of doing a little extra work,
looking up a few other things,
making a few more phone calls,
doing a little bit of more
research, and being right,
and my residents didn't think
that was the right answer,
and it was-- I love
that, I love that.
So here we are operating
and solving a problem,
and we're in the operating room.
We're trying to figure out which
way to approach this child's
brain lesion that needs to
come out, this is a big team,
this is all team efforts now.
And it's so rewarding
to solve the problem
and have the child wake
up and not be paralyzed.
And then when the parents
send you photographs,
fingers up, thumbs up, it is
so rewarding, is so rewarding,
how can you tear
yourself away from it.
And now we can do fMRI's
of these kinds of rewards,
we can see them now, we
know where they live.
In they're part of the
same rewards network.
So, doctors are--
at least my doctors
that I know-- are really
rewarded by problem solving,
and by altruism, and this is
part of our reward system.
However, even this
can be overtaking.
So, in 2007 I was chairman of
the ethics committee of one
of our big national
organizations
of pediatric
neurosurgery, that happen
because I missed
a meeting, so they
made me chairman of
the ethics committee.
And I said, I'll
get you, I'm going
to do something as I'm chairman
of the ethics committee.
And we're going to have a forum,
because this was globalization.
There's a lot of interest
in international outreach,
with neurosurgery.
On the other hand,
I had a mentor
who once said to all of
us when we were getting
a little big for our britches,
if all the neurosurgeons
in the world went up
in a puff of smoke
tomorrow, the amount of human
suffering that would be changed
would be one drop
in the vast ocean.
And that's true, neurosurgeons
are not so important,
despite what you hear.
And it kept a perspective
of mind, because he said,
you know if you're really
going to make a difference,
you're going to go
solve malnutrition
and infectious diseases, and
population, this what you do
is not that important in
the scheme of things--
And I took to heart.
But this was a survey that
I did as head of the ethics
committee, giving my
colleagues about 200
of us in the country, various
things to think about,
resource allocation,
should you do something
if somebody has to
pay out-of-pocket,
should you do it if
the child probably
isn't gonna live even if
you help that suffering,
should you do it under
these circumstances.
And here's what was
fascinating to me,
they really believed that no
matter how hopeless it was,
they would be happy to help.
This is a Likert scale, strongly
disagree, strongly agree,
this is number of responses.
And they strongly
disagreed with the concept
that in a finite
resource situation
you can't help everybody
it's not justified,
they strongly
disagree with that.
And I'm surprised
by this, I thought
that my colleagues
would have kind
of a different view of
the big world pictures,
and they didn't,
because they actually
felt it was wrong to
think about this stuff.
They said, it's not my shift
to think about resource
allocation, it's not my shift
to think about the planet,
it's my shift like a lawyer
taking care of a client,
whether they're
guilty or not, it's
my shift to take care
of that suffering
that I see in front of me.
And I thought that
that was interesting,
it's how their brains work,
they're rewarded, by what,
problem solving, altruism.
And this other stuff,
feeling like maybe we're
part of the problem,
because we spend
so much resources
on so few people,
is a conflict, so not my shift.
I, on the other hand, still
felt like it was my shift,
and I felt increasingly
distressed by the fact
that even in medicine,
which is 18 percent
of our gross domestic product.
We have enormous waste, we
produce enormous carbon,
we do it and feel good about
it because it's helping people.
One of the questions that was
asked when we did our trial
balloon last year at HUCE, at
the Center for the Environment
was this, just because
reward circuitry
and the new understanding
of it, is neat
doesn't mean it's relevant
to these questions.
And I think that's a
really valid question.
Does neuroscience add value to
understanding these behaviors,
just because I can
do a functional
MRI on the physician that
shows up their altruism center.
Does this help us at all?
Does it add any value to
what the psychologists, who
are very good at this and
looking at it carefully,
already do.
And I think my answer
is, I don't know yet,
but I am intrigued by the
modulatability of the reward
system and all the inputs.
An example that my students
and I have come up with
is the idea of
medieval cats-- now
you're going to think I'm
crazy, she said threads,
but these are all
over the place.
So, in the Middle
Ages, those of you
who are Middle Ages
scholars, know this.
Cats were considered
a sign of the devil,
that the devil
actually lived in cats.
And so, in public squares,
there was a great glee
taken by rounding up
cats and torturing them,
burning them alive.
And the more they
squealed and squawked,
and writhe in agony,
the happier people were,
the more they thought the
devil was being squelched.
You would probably, I
would say with confidence,
I think most of you
would be horrified.
This would not
give you a reward.
That's your reward system
being modulated by context,
and there's a lot written about
that largely by psychologists.
But, we are starting
to understand
how that modulation occurs,
because of these new insights
into how the reward system makes
these modulations possible.
And it's an extraordinary, and
I will say beautiful, system.
However, we also need to know,
does our individual consumption
matter, is it about what
we do individually or is
it mathematically
about the way we live,
or how corporations
work, and so forth.
I would say that so far,
my students working on this
have come up with
things that suggests
it's about half and half.
That it is our
individual behavior,
it's not like that
10% of the problem,
it's somewhere in the 40
to 60% of the range, what
we individually can control.
And the rest of it we
would have to control
through political and other
means, to change big things.
So how about the medical
field, that's the one
I live in, how about in
organizations like hospitals.
So again, I'm not going to talk
a whole lot about that now,
but I'd be happy to
talk to some of you,
I've been talking to people at
the school of public health.
I will say that thinking
about brain and climate change
isn't new, I didn't know
others we're doing this
and that sort of
exploration is all about.
The American
Psychological Association
had a task force on this,
but they were really focus
more on perception
of risk, and the fact
that it's a beautiful
day out today,
it's hard to perceive
that environmental decline
and climate change is a risk.
Like it is easy to perceive a
tiger about to pounce on you.
And that also is the
way our brains evolved,
and how we perceived risk.
There's something called the
Garrison Institute, some of you
may be familiar with, and
they have a climate mind
and behavior seminar, and this
is a quote from their program
rationale for this climate
minded behavior seminar,
their idea is that if we
apply a behavioral lens
to environmental
policy and regulation,
and taken into account the way
the human wiring has evolved,
it'll be more effect.
So I would say knowing what
we know about the brain,
does this make sense, is our
wiring getting us into trouble?
If so, can it be modified,
and is it changing over time.
So that's the set
up for theme three.
All along the time that I've
been interested in this topic,
I've also been amazed at
how things are changing
for our young children.
And when I started in my
practice 30 years ago,
a baby would be brought into
the office by its parents,
with a teething toy
and a stuffed animal.
And now the most common
thing that a baby
is brought into the office with,
even very young babies three,
four, five months
of age, is an iPad.
And at first when
they start happening
I was, sort of
bummed out about it,
but it happen more,
and more, and more.
And even if they
don't have an iPad,
the parent, when the
baby starts to cry,
will pull out the phone, and
put something on the phone.
And you see, extraordinarily
young children knowing how
to swipe and point.
Now, the initial reaction of
those of us, who are my age,
is to think this is bad.
But it isn't necessarily
bad, and that's
what neuroscience
does, it gives you
that arm's length, is
that modern life probably,
in my opinion, is going to
change our blank brains.
And that's because plasticity
is so robust early in life,
this is one of the
things I do study,
some of my lab colleagues
are here today.
And I study because it
happens in front of my eyes,
one of things about being a
neurosurgeon in pediatrics
is, it's a front row seat.
This little boy had a 200 pound
tractor tire fall on his head,
and crush his head, and
had a severe brain injury.
Here he is still comatose,
but his eyes are awake,
he's in that form of comma
were your eyes are awake.
And here the lights
have come back on,
his brother's is
fooling around with him.
And here's the recovery.
This is what we see every
day, this is our currency.
We count on this
and we observe it,
and I had never ever
got at least bit tired
of seeing the brain
recover in a child,
whether it's something
I did to that child,
or something mother
nature or accident did.
And we study this
in my lab, we study
how you can injure an area,
there's an area of function
before, after an
injury goes away
and it starts to come
back somewhere else.
And my colleague, Dr.
[? Costeen, ?] studies
how these cells try to
reorganize, new cells are made,
and at what age this occurs.
But what I can tell you is,
all the evidence points to this
is really maximal,
early in life.
And we know this, we know
this from anthropology.
This slide on the left, came
from a colleague of mine
who's a pediatrician, and
a cultural anthropologist.
Who showed me that toddlers,
in certain cultures,
can learn very early
to use dangerous
sharp implements
to cut open fruits,
because they do, because
they practice it,
because they do, just
like Suzuki violin.
You don't have a kid off
the street play the violin,
but you can because
of that plasticity,
and this is the same
kind of plasticity.
And in fact, this new
plasticity is so appealing,
because it appeals
to so many things
in our attention getting
mechanisms and our reward
system, all at once that
it's like nothing in nature.
And that's why this
violin doesn't have
a chance, next to that iPad.
And again, I'm not
saying it's evil or bad,
I'm just saying it
appeals to everything
that we evolve to find
attention-getting,
and that's why it's so
appealing to children.
So theme three is about
plasticity in modern life.
Are our brains changing,
I think it's unequivocal
that our brains are changing,
due to this kind of exposure.
Is it good or bad, I'm
not here to say that.
It maybe good and bad, it
may depend on the child,
it may depend on many
things and I'm not
going to solve that problem, but
there are people working on it.
But, I am curious about
whether it has implications
for consumption, if you are
stimulated to a high level,
we know your attention
system can't upregulate.
Does it mean you
need more novelty,
does more novelty
translate to more stuff?
Do you need more stuff?
Do you need more stimulation?
Are there ways to
get stimulation
that don't require stuff?
And I've had people
say, iPads are great,
because now you
could have one device
and the kid is
stimulated forever,
and you don't have to buy
any more stuff, that's
one argument, could be true.
So then we'll start
to wrap this together,
is any of this relevant,
are any of these themes
relevant, how might using a
neurological science brain-lens
be useful in changing
behavior, and these
are suggestions that other have
floated, people we've studied.
There's a wonderful
writer, Per Stoknes,
who's a Swedish psychologist,
who has written an entire book,
it's at the Harvard
bookstore, What
We Think About When
We're Trying Not
To Think About Global Warming.
His focus really
is on our reaction
to the idea of global warming,
not our daily behavior,
but his point is, you have to
frame the argument differently.
So,-- what I think--
we've come up with,
and others have come up with,
and again we're early on, that
we can't depend on people doing
with less and simplifying,
that's not the way it works.
But you can facilitate getting
select stuff, and the rewards
of experience, relationships,
and even the rewards of nature,
if you believe that Biophilia is
a real thing that we all have.
And if you add stuff
in, with a bargain,
it's even more rewarding.
So, Alice Flaherty who was
one of my collaborators
on the beginning of
this project said,
I get my kicks for
shopping out at eBay,
I can get something for
$2, I get a good new thing
and I feel great about eco-side
of it because it's recycled.
You know, that's
getting a reward,
and the reward
get double reward.
You can play into
socially rewards,
this is a lot of
what Stoknes says,
you can change behavior
because the neighbors do it--
you all get your electricity
bill, or your oil bill
and it says your neighbors use
less or more, that turns out--
that stuff in the hotel, about
75% of people rooms like yours,
didn't through their
towels on the floor--
that stuff turns out to
be quite effective when
the social scientists
have studied it.
You can enhance community,
look at California
with the water savings.
Nobody thought
that would happen,
but they're almost
in competition
with the next community
about who can do best.
So these are the
kinds of rewards
you're playing into
the reward system,
instead of telling
people, just do it less.
You can appeal to Biophilia,
something positive to get,
that's a Stoknes idea, and also
it's very prevalent right now
in the movement
for green buildings
and Biophilic buildings.
So, you get a
positive thing, plus
it turns out that, the
next bullet point down, you
can incentivize
health, economic,
and aesthetic benefits, because
it turns out green buildings
actually are better
for your health.
And the folks here
at the Harvard School
of Public Health, whom I
been communicating with,
have shown that with definitive
data, which is a great thing.
You can capitalize on the
reward system, quirks,
small, variable, unexpected,
how about if every,
5th to 10th electricity bill,
you get a bonus just for fun,
you probably push that
button like the rats do.
Recognize the power of
contextual plasticity,
like the cat story.
If the thing is
framed differently,
the reward something,
that's very rewarding,
can be horrifying
and vice versa,
that's our nervous
system at work,
it's because of all the
input from different parts
of our nervous
system that modulate
how the rewards are valued.
And really the bottom
line that we're
learning, as we slog through
some of this really interesting
stuff, I don't
like the word slog,
as we have the opportunity
to expose ourselves
to this stuff-- there's
a lot of it, that's
where the word slog popped
through my unconscious--
is to do more research,
there's so much
that could be done
about plasticity.
We're also interested
in adolescence,
this idea of the prolonged
adolescence, from 18 to 25
that folks are studying.
What about the consumptive
behavior at that time?
And I'm interested bringing
this back to the medical field
to see if I can incentivize my
colleagues, as an experiment,
to add in sustainability
as an additional rewards
to that altruism
and problem-solving.
Finally, I want to wrap up by
saying that, somebody said this
to me once, not knowing
that this is what I do,
people do interdisciplinary
work because they
failed at their primary job.
But I would say, we evolved
to be different from one
another, that was a survival
technique, the mixing of genes,
the mixing of experience,
makes each of us unique,
and some people have brains
that like to connect dots,
and I would say
that's the way I have
worked throughout my career.
I'm going to end
with this story.
This little boy
had epilepsy, that
was from a disease
that is progressive.
And it's an interesting
disease, it's
called Rasmussen's Encephalitis,
and the only known cure
is to take out, or
disable half the brain.
This, as luck would have
it, was on the dominant side
of his brain, such that
if we disabled that half
of his brain, he had a high
risk of losing speech forever,
never be able to understand
or produce speech,
and he would become paralyzed
on his dominant side.
So planning this survey, people
think surgery, neurosurgery,
is all about being
in the operating,
it's actually all
the planning, and all
the counseling, and all the
thinking about alternatives,
making sure families
know what you're doing.
And, it took about a year
to get this boy ultimately
to the point where his
parents, and the boy himself,
wanted surgery for his
epilepsy, which was progressing,
and ultimately untreated would
have disabled him totally.
So the parents went through
surgery, that period of time,
the hardest thing--
the minutes you
lose of your life
in my business,
is the time you
finish the operation,
to the time the
patient wakes up,
and you find out if they can
still recognize their mother.
That's where you
lose off your life,
and he did wake up and
recognize his mother,
he had to relearn to
speak, although he did.
And mom sent me this
photograph of him,
climbing up to a rocky hiking
area, in New Hampshire,
and climbing to the top of
this observation fire tower.
And she liked this one, because
he was determined to do,
and two, because she likes this
picture because he was looking
out over his future--
into his future--
it was symbolic to
her that he did this,
and she took that photograph
and sent it to those of us
on the team.
And I will say, that tweaks
your altruism reward, right?
That's tweaks your
problem-solving.
We did a really
innovative thing to decide
what to do this child,
and this big team
in the operating room,
trying to figure out and make
the right choices
as we were doing it.
It got written up in the New
England Journal of Medicine,
it's very satisfying.
And I could quit there, and we
could have the violins play,
and it would be a great
story, and you might even
get out your Kleenex.
but, I don't think
I'm done, I don't
think that's the future--
that's the only future that's
my responsibility, I think the
rest of the future out there,
of all the other kids is
also my responsibility.
And I hope, that through this
exploration maybe our team,
and others like you, can
contribute a little bit
to connecting those dots.
So, thank you.